good afternoon everyone it's my pleasure
to introduce Dr Mara Carlin performing
the duties of the Deputy under secretary
of defense for policy who will provide
some brief remarks about the ocus
optimal pathway announced by President
Biden yesterday this is a trilateral
commitments-based phase plan for
Australia to acquire conventionally
armed nuclear-powered submarines please
note Dr Carlin will have time for a few
questions afterwards and then must
depart I'd ask that you please limit
your questions to August given that's
her Focus here today and then after a
brief pause I'll Stick Around to provide
some non-ocus updates and answer
questions as well so thank you for your
assistance on this Dr Carlin over to you
man all right thanks so much good
afternoon it's great to see you all
yesterday you heard from President Biden
prime minister Albanese and prime
minister sunac on the agreement for
Australia to acquire a conventionally
armed nuclear-powered submarine
capability through the Australia United
Kingdom United States enhanced security
partnership or August yesterday
concluded our 18-month thorough and
expert-led consultation period to
identify the optimal pathway for
Australia to acquire this capability
while setting the highest nuclear
non-proliferation standard this plan
will deliver on that commitment and lift
all three nations submarine industrial
bases and undersea capabilities
enhancing deterrence and promoting
stability in the indo-pacific for the
last seven decades our three countries
have stood shoulder to shoulder along
with our allies and partners to help
sustain peace and stability in the
indo-pacific the optimal pathway will
sustain that in the decisive decades
ahead as the National Security strategy
and National defense strategy describe
the United States must pursue a free
open and secure world to protect our
national interests and those of our
allies and our partners August advances
this goal by building our military
capabilities and those of two of our
very closest allies enabling closer
military planning and cooperation it is
a gen generational opportunity to
enhance the National Security of all
three nations as the president shared in
his remarks yesterday the optimal
pathway will deliver deterrence across
several phases under the first phase of
the optimal pathway the United States
and the United Kingdom will immediately
increase Port visits of conventionally
armed nuclear-powered submarines in
Australia and then as early as 2027 will
begin rotating through Australia under
submarine rotational Force West this
deployment will ensure Australian
Personnel can continue familiarizing
themselves with how these vessels
operate how they are properly maintained
and how we can continue safely operating
together the increased presence of U.S
submarines will buttress Regional
stability and support the safe
development of Australian stewardship of
its own Sovereign conventionally armed
nuclear-powered submarine Enterprise in
the next phase the United States intends
to sell three virginia-class submarines
to Australia in the 2030s with the
potential to sell up to two more if
needed this this will provide Australia
with a conventionally armed
nuclear-powered submarine capability
prior to their enduring Sovereign
capability coming online you will see
three Allied and highly interoperable
SSN fleets operating in the indo-pacific
the Final Phase will be our support for
what we call SSN August a Next
Generation conventionally armed
nuclear-powered submarine designed and
constructed by Australia and the UK and
incorporating cutting-edge U.S
Technologies in the propulsion plant
combat control and weapon systems
Australia's acquisition of ssns will
bolster the capabilities of one of our
strongest allies by increasing the Royal
Australian Navy's range survivability
and striking power thus strengthening
deterrence in the indo-pacific
every phase of the optimal pathway will
set the highest nuclear
non-proliferation standards moreover
August will diversify U.S posture in the
indo-pacific offering new locations from
which U.S forces can operate and August
will strengthen U.S and Allied submarine
industrial capacity which is key to
modernizing innovating and maintaining
our military and economic Competitive
Edge today and in the future three
highly capable Allied and interoperable
submarine forces will strengthen U.S
national security and buttress stability
in the indo-pacific for decades to come
we are also working to modernize our
information sharing and Export Control
Systems which is necessary for the
effective implementation of August as
the national defense strategy outlines
the capacity to share information with
key allies and partners is of critical
importance to how the United States
deters aggression and succeeds in
contingencies we will work closely with
the U.S government including the
Congress of course and the United
Kingdom and Australia to identify
obstacles to information sharing and to
develop Innovative rapid and scalable
solutions to develop to deliver on the
president's vision for this historic
partnership and with that I'd be
delighted to take your questions thank
you very much ma'am all right go to the
answer for questions yes sir
um have you had any uh Direct
Communications with other militaries
airing concerns or issues about the
orcas deal and if so what have they been
and also just on um the selection of the
virginia-class submarines that you you
will eventually sell to Australia what's
the criteria for which submarines you
select and how and when you deliver them
I want to make sure I understand the
first part of your questions when you've
talked about Communications with
militaries are you citing specific
allies partners
China to asean countries any other
foreign military great uh we have had a
number of conversations with our allies
and our partners in civilian channels
and Military channels of course
throughout the consultative period and
then of course in the run-up to
yesterday's announcement and have heard
a substantial amount of enthusiasm from
them for this historic game-changing uh
partnership regarding engagements with
the People's Republic of China the state
department did do that and I would refer
to you I would refer you to them for the
substance of that dialogue I would of
course highlight what you've heard often
from secretary Austin which is that open
communication between our two countries
is important for risk management and for
understanding what one another is
thinking
and then on your second question
regarding uh Virginia
um you know why we chose that we looked
at a wide number of options it has been
a robust and very busy 18 months of uh
of consultations and trying to look at a
wide variety of options in terms of
which submarine specifically will go uh
that will will go to rotate for
submarine rotational forces West that's
really going to be figured out through
our normal military processes of such
efforts
row
okay uh thank you very much for doing
this I have two questions about the
submarine location Force West uh can you
say the new locational force will
increase the total number of U.S
submarine operating in the Western
Pacific compared to today
and then do you have another question oh
yeah yeah then secondly can you tell us
uh can you talk a little bit about
advantage of having a rotational
presence of the U.S submarine outside of
the second island chain in terms of
deterring Chinese aggression in the
region
all right uh on on that first one uh
heparating capable submarines around the
indo-pacific is really critical for
security and stability and I think that
really tracks nicely to your next
question which look to be very clear
August is not about any one country it
is about the need for security stability
and prosperity in the indo-pacific and
our three countries of course have a
robust uh history of collaborating
together this is going to take us to
another level of interoperability I
would highlight the significance of
sharing this information with Australia
as you all probably know the last time
we did so it was 1958 so it's really a
sign of just how close this relationship
is for that to really occur in a
responsible way it's important that
Australia develop stewardship practices
and that's why we have developed this
multi-phased Mutual commitments approach
let's go to Will
thank you
um regarding the um the Virginia class
submarines that that Australia will
purchase in the 2030s has has a specific
model been selected or is that something
that's a little bit down the road and it
will basically be what's on the
production line for the US is purchasing
at that point will they be equipped with
the the vpm to increase missile capacity
or is it something tailored to Australia
specifically
so first of all it's worth noting that
Australia will get these Subs in just
about a decade that is frankly faster
than I suspect a lot of folks might have
expected and this whole effort was
announced just 18 months ago Australia
will be purchasing a mix of new new
submarines and old submarines and it uh
right now it looks like it will be two
with the potential to have excuse me it
will be three with the potential for two
more uh if needed as I noted earlier uh
the the cohort of folks looked at a wide
range of different options and really
came came down with Virginia as the re
as the right approach uh and Virginia
payload module will not be be a part of
it I think the three countries saw that
that didn't make sense uh as you no
doubt know well of course these
submarines are going to be especially
special though because of their stealth
their range and their endurance so they
really will will be kind of a meaningful
meaningful deterrent in the region
to go to gym
it's good to see you
um I'm the info sharing going back to
the question you answered just just a
little bit before is that is that a real
showstopper I mean these these countries
are all five eye participants you don't
really anticipate that being a a problem
with the info sharing with Australia do
you you know Jim allies and partners are
at the heart of the national defense
strategy right they're a center of
gravity for realizing that 2022 National
defense strategy and we know we have to
lower the barriers to working with them
and information is just a piece of it
you're exactly right that these are two
of our very closest allies who we have
stood shoulder to shoulder with for much
of the last hundred years or so uh
nevertheless nevertheless we have
processes that have to be figured out
and to ensure that both pillars of
August right there are two pillars today
we're very focused on pillar one which
is the uh the the conventionally armed
nuclear-powered submarines but there's
also pillar too right this cooperation
on Advanced capabilities we know for
that to be realized we're going to need
very uh clear transparent robust
information sharing practices it's a
great case study these are exactly the
right to allies to make it real and we
look forward to working with our
colleagues around the US government
including the Congress to to make that a
reality
time for just a couple more
Joe
hi thanks for doing this
um Joe gold defense news um just to
follow up on Jim's question I mean what
are the can you drill down a little bit
to talk about what are the specific
obstacles do you have a sense I mean
after 18 months do you have a sense of
what some of the the pieces of itar and
what kind of information sharing needs
to get changed
figuring out how we can ensure that we
deliver on this historic game changing
pledge by the three heads of state and
so we've looked hard at the different
changes that might need to happen but I
would say that there there's probably
more to be done along those lines but I
can assure you that we will do all we
can to both deliver on the submarines
and to deliver on the advanced
capabilities piece we are in very close
consultation with our colleagues at the
state department on the itarp
specifically and also with our
colleagues in in Congress but on the
whole I think we've all been pleased to
see robust bipartisan support for making
this a reality and really recognizing
the sort of generational leap that we
see in this Alliance
thank you very much ma'am I appreciate
your time thank you
all right thank you all very much uh
just a few things at the top and then
I'll get right to your questions uh so
first of all
um I would like to highlight U.S
European commands statement released
earlier today confirming that two
Russian su-27 aircraft conducted unsafe
and unprofessional and unprofessional
intercept with a U.S Air Force
intelligence surveillance and
reconnaissance unmanned MQ-9 aircraft
that was operating within International
airspace over the Black Sea today to
recap at approximately 703 am Central
European Time one of the Russian su-27
aircraft struck the propeller of the
MQ-9 causing U.S forces to have to bring
the MQ-9 down in international waters
several times before the Collision the
su-27s dumped fuel on and flew in front
of the MQ-9 in a reckless and
unprofessional manner this incident
demonstrates a lack of competence in
addition to being unsafe and
unprofessional
U.S air forces in Europe Air Forces
Africa routinely fly aircraft throughout
Europe over Sovereign territory and
throughout International airspace in
coordination with applicable host nation
and international laws in order to
bolster Collective European Defense and
security these missions support Allied
partner and U.S national objectives
as the U.S air forces in Europe Air
Forces Africa Commander emphasized in
European command statement quote U.S and
Allied aircraft will continue to operate
an international airspace and we call on
the Russians to connect conduct
themselves professionally and safely
in separate news secretary Austin
concluded a successful visit to the
Middle East region last week where he
met with leaders in Jordan Iraq Egypt
and Israel the week-long trip served a
deep in defense Partnerships and enable
the exchange of views on shared Regional
and Global Security challenges
specific topics of discussion included
ongoing coalition-led defeat Isis
operations in Iraq and Syria the
concerning range of threats posed by
Iran including its destabilizing
Regional activities and provision of
unmanned aerial systems to Russia for
use in their unprovoked war against
Ukraine and implementing commitments
made by Israeli and Palestinian senior
officials in akba Jordan and the
importance of de-escalating violence and
restoring calm in the West Bank the
secretary also had the opportunity to
talk to a number of U.S service members
currently serving in the U.S Central
Command area of responsibility and thank
them and their families for their
commitment to Mission service and
safeguarding our nation
and finally secretary Austin and
chairman of the Joint Chiefs of Staff
General milley will host the 10th
meeting of the Ukraine defense contact
group tomorrow the meeting will be
hosted virtually here in the Pentagon
and will allow for the secretary the
chairman and Senior defense leaders from
around the world to discuss ongoing
efforts to provide Ukraine with the
means and resources it needs to defend
itself from Russian aggression
additional information on tomorrow's
meeting will be forthcoming and with
that I will take your questions we'll
start with the Reuters Phil as the
secretary or anyone else in the U.S
military reached out to uh his Russian
counterpart or anyone else's
counterparts from Russia and regarding
the MQ-9 uh you know what can you detail
a little bit more what its mission was
and where was being piloted from yeah
sure so in terms of uh secretary Austin
uh talking his counterpart not at this
time to my knowledge
DOD officials have not spoken
specifically to Russian authorities on
this particular incident I do know that
the state department is raising our
concerns about the incident directly
with the Russian government so I'd refer
you to them for details on that in terms
of the the mission of the MQ-9 as I
mentioned it's an ISR platform you know
these these aircraft have been flying
over the Black Sea region for some time
to include before the current conflict
started it is an important and busy
International Waterway uh and so it is
uh not an uncommon mission for us to be
flying an international airspace
was this aircraft armed uh so I'm not
going to get into the specific uh
profile of this particular aircraft as
you know the MQ-9 does have the ability
to be armed it was again conducting an
ISR mission in international airspace
something that we've been doing for some
time in terms of the types of tactic
techniques and procedures that we take
to protect our aircraft I'm not going to
get into the specifics I think the key
Point here is that while intercepts in
and of themselves are not that uncommon
the fact that this type of behavior from
these Russian Pilots that is uncommon
and unfortunate and unsafe and so again
what Echo General heckers call on the
Russians to continue to
fly safely thank you Liz
was this Collision itself an accident on
Russia's behalf and is the U.S
responding as such
um so
you know we are continuing to assess
exactly what happened but I think based
on the actions of the Russian Pilots
it's clear that it was unsafe
unprofessional
um and I think the actions speak for
themselves what we what we saw again
were fighter aircraft dumping fuel in
front of this UAV and then getting so
close to the aircraft that it actually
damaged the propeller on the MQ-9 we we
assessed that it likely caused some
damage to the Russian aircraft as well
to our knowledge well we know that the
aircraft the Russian aircraft did land
I'm not going to go into where they
landed
but again it just demonstrative of uh
very unprofessional unsafe airmanship on
the part of these Pilots one more
question sorry
um will the U.S try to recover this
drone uh so I'm not I don't have
anything right now to provide in terms
of recovery operations if we have any
updates to provide and we'll be sure to
do that thanks
David
is there video of the incident are you
going to release the video
where in the Black Sea did it happen how
close
to Russian airspace
and did you say that this particular
Reaper was unarmed again I didn't say
whether it was or was not I'm not going
to get into the particular Mission
profile of this aircraft it was
conducting an ISR Mission
um
in terms of the specifics David I'm not
going to at this point be able to get
more specific other than the Black Sea
region in international airspace well
well clear of of any type of
yeah it was International airspace and
I'm sorry the other part of your
question the video yes so we are going
through the the declassification process
now and we'll keep you updated on that
front in terms of imagery associated
with this incident
dress
I'm laser focused on your question that
was just a very quick one um you haven't
said Reaper but he said Reaper is it
accurate to say it's MQ-9 Reaper
I'm just going to stick with MQ-9 yep
thanks Joe
hi thanks so much Pat um
the uh an MQ-9 potentially contains
sensitive technology is the U.S military
undertaking any effort to recover the
MQ-9 is it in the is it in the waters of
the Black Sea has Russia recovered it
um is there a U.S naval asset in the in
the region that could undertake that
recovery thanks yeah so uh again I'm not
going to get into the specifics of
what's on this particular aircraft
um other than again it's an ISR platform
uh because of the damage we were in a
position to have to essentially
um crash it into the Black Sea uh to my
knowledge at this point in time
the Russians have not recovered that
aircraft but again in terms of our
recovery efforts don't have any updates
to provide right now I'd refer you to
navier in terms of what assets they may
have in that region thank you
regarding the North Korea's summary in
Ranchi the Strategic cruise missiles
recently North Korea has announced that
it is possible to monitor nuclear
warhead on a strategic cruise missiles
what is the Readiness of the United
States against the Escalade provocations
such as the nuclear provocation by the
North Korea
let me just make sure I understand
what's the Readiness of the U.S to
respond to a nuclear provocation by
North Korea
well I think we've been very clear that
were North Korea to employ a nuclear
weapon it would be the end of the North
Korean regime but again our Focus
continues to be on working very closely
with our allies and our partners in the
region to deter aggression to preserve
security and stability in the region and
that will continue to be our our Focus
you go to Carla
education
what did the fighter jet what did he
strike the the MQ-9 with was it the wing
was it yeah uh I can't tell you
specifically what portion of the
aircraft but uh is the fact that it
essentially ran into the MQ-9 okay thank
you and then just separately on Ukraine
there's reports out there from the the
battlefield that the ukrainians are
running out of Munitions they're having
shortages is that a concern for the
Pentagon what's the Pentagon doing to
alleviate that problem yeah so as we've
been doing since the beginning of this
campaign we're continuing to do
everything that we can to ensure that
we're meeting Ukraine's needs whether
it's ammunition whether it's air defense
armor uh you know you've heard us talk
extensively about that tomorrow's
discussion of course will be another
opportunity to bring the International
Community together to focus on Ukraine's
most urgent needs to include ammunition
and so uh again that will continue to be
our focus and and you've heard secretary
Austin and others say that we're
committed to making sure that they have
what they to be successful
so thanks is there an assessment that
the Pentagon has on why they're running
out of ammunition is it because they're
just expending it too fast is it not
making it to the battlefield in time
what's yours yeah it really is I'd have
to refer you the ukrainians to talk
about their specific efforts to supply
their individual units again we're
working very closely with them and our
International Partners to get them what
they need
um and and I think it's also important
to kind of take a step back and look at
the progress that has been made while
recognizing the fact that there still is
a tough fight ahead particularly as we
go into the the spring and summer and so
our our Focus again is going to be
working with national armed directors
with the ukrainians to get them the
ammunition they need and get that to the
front line units as quickly as possible
let me go back over to this side of the
room yes sir
thank you can you guide us through the
timeline of the MQ-9 intercept uh we
have that the aircraft was struck at 703
eastern time but uh how long were the
sukhoys with the aircraft beforehand and
were there any Radio Calls between radio
communications either from the Russians
or from the United States
yeah so on the latter part of your
question no none that I'm aware of
um
and uh I would ask that you go back and
confirm this with UConn but but based on
the information I have here it seems
like uh
approximately
30 to 40 minutes uh they were flying in
the vicinity of this MQ-9 uh and then at
703 is when the
um 73 a.m Central European Time is when
they collided causing it to crash so
awesome
U.S forces has had to bring down the the
aircraft does that mean that the United
States piloted it to the crash site or
was it struck by mslr yeah we brought it
down
also
um is there any U.S naval assets
currently in in black seed again I'd
have to refer you to uh navier for any
details on particular Assets in the
region thank you Laura
thanks
um can you talk a little bit more about
the damage to the MQ-9 was it unfiable
and and that's why you had to bring it
down
um and then can you say a little bit
more about how often this kind of thing
happens in over the Black Sea that
Russian aircraft harass U.S drones and
and other aircraft
yeah so I don't have any statistics in
front of me in terms of intercepts but
again as I highlighted the fact that
uh
intercepts of aircraft are not uncommon
in and of themselves it's not obviously
a daily occurrence the vast majority of
those intercepts are what we would
consider safe and professional just
wanting to see what's there right you're
flying alongside it to to be able to see
what's there in this particular case
though again they collided with the
aircraft damaging the propeller and
essentially putting in a situation where
it was unfiable and uncontrollable so we
brought it down thank you time for a few
more go here and then to buff body
hi sir thanks I just wanted to check to
confirm any communication with allies
such as turkey about potential recovery
of the Drone and is there any concern
that Russia could provide the Drone to
Iran if it recovers it uh so that that
would be hypothetical again Russia does
not have the Drone so that would be a
hypothetical question in terms of
working with allies and partners I don't
have anything to announce here but if
and when we do we'll be sure to let you
know thank you go to fatty and then
we'll come back over here to last you
yep
uh thank you General someone
um I know you don't want to share lots
of information special intelligence
information but are you able to say
whether the MQ-9 was flying
um near Ukraine or near the Crimea
Peninsula and then I believe you said if
I heard right that the Russians did not
recover the uh the Drone however have
you seen any effort by the Russian Navy
to try to recover the Drone thank you
yeah so on your latter question there
fatty I'm not going to get into that
um in terms of where it was flying
um it was well clear of any territory in
Ukraine it was over International in
international airspace over
International water so thank you Nancy
thank you um during secretary Austin's
visit to Egypt he held meetings with
officials even though all press were
banned from covering it past defense
Chiefs when they've been in a similar
situation have refused to proceed given
that the Biden Administration has said
that one of its key pillars in terms of
foreign policy is that one presented
with the a choice between autocrats and
democracies that it stands with
democracies can you help us understand
why the secretary decided to proceed
with those trips given the ban and
should we expect that going forward
thank you thank you so our relationship
with Egypt is obviously a very important
uh strategic partnership the secretary
did appreciate the opportunity to meet
with his counterparts uh and talk about
that I will tell you when it come when
it came to the Press coverage of that
portion having looked further into it
the Egyptians loved lived up to what
they had agreed upon some of the Lessons
Learned out of that was in terms of
making sure that we were on the same
sheet when it came to understanding
press access and so we will continue to
work that I'm sorry
beforehand that there would be a ban of
journalists we did not agree to a ban on
journalists we agreed to have official
photographers we did have one reporter
come into one of the sessions but then a
portion that was going to be open to the
Press was subsequently not held and
therefore there was an opportunity to
cover that but again
sometimes these meetings are are very
small sometimes there's not the
opportunity for media to come in but
again it's something that we've noted
and will continue to work closely with
governments as we visit to ensure that
there's press access
thank you
sir
just regarding the budget for the last
few years the services have pursued a
divest to invest strategy and Congress
hasn't necessarily bought into that this
year the Air Force is looking to retire
more than 300 aircraft double the amount
last year again Congress last year
didn't give that full amount is there a
sense that things have changed on the
hill that there's a willingness to
approve greater divestment or is this
now becoming kind of a cat and mouse
game of shoot with a higher number
knowing you're going to get less to try
to get to where you want to be
well when it comes to the Air Force
budget specifically a course would refer
you to them to talk in specifics and and
I don't want to answer for congress what
I will say is having observed this
process I do think like anything there's
a continuing dialogue in terms of what
the services require to meet their
mission requirements and and working
closely with Congress and with the
Department of Defense to identify what
those offsets might be in order to
ensure that we can modernize uh you know
throughout all the services and so I
think in a lot of ways is that
communication has increased you're
seeing some of the the fruits of that
labor but again I'd refer you to the Air
Force for specifics on their budget okay
thank you very much everybody appreciate
it